wir werden
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
liebe
freundinnen und freunde
das ist heute ein ganz besonderer
wahlabend
zum ersten mal
seit 16 jahren
hat angela merkel nicht mehr als
bundeskanzlerin kann und kandidiert das
waren 16 gute jahre für deutschland und
deshalb gilt mein erster dank der
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel für ihre
arbeit
aber
und zwar klar
und zwar klar ohne amtsbonus wird dass
ein offener ein harter wahlkampf
und so ist es auch gekommen
es ist ein kopf an kopf rennen dieser
wahlabend ist eine ausnahme situation
wir haben derzeit noch keine gesicherten
endergebnisse keine gesicherten zahlen
aber wir können jetzt schon sagen mit
dem ergebnis können wir nicht zufrieden
sein
und trotzdem der ausgang der wahl ist
noch völlig unklar es wird ein langer
abend und in jedem fall stellt das
wahlergebnis
deutschland die union
alle demokratischen parteien vor große
herausforderungen
wir müssen die weichen stellen für die
zwanziger jahre
das kann keine partei alleine und
deshalb bedarf es jetzt einer großen
kraftanstrengung aller demokratinnen und
demokraten
wir müssen gegensätze überwinden und
deutschland zusammen halten es wird
erstmals
aller voraussicht nach eine
bundesregierung mit drei
bündnispartnern geben können und wir als
union haben von unseren wählerinnen und
wählern einen klaren auftrag erhalten
eine stimme für die union ist eine
stimme gegen eine links geführte
bundesregierung
und deshalb
deshalb werden wir alles daran setzen
eine bundesregierung unter führung der
union zu bilden denn deutschland
deutschland
deutschland braucht jetzt eine zukunfts
koalition die unser land modernisiert
deutschland braucht eine koalition für
mehr nachhaltigkeit in jeder hinsicht
beim klimaschutz und bei den finanzen
wir tragen verantwortung für die
künftigen generationen
für unsere kinder und enkel und dieser
verantwortung müssen wir stärker gerecht
werden als bisher gerade beim
klimaschutz wir brauchen eine koalition
die unser land schneller macht und
digitalisiert dass unser land von
fesseln befreit und bei plan und
genehmigungsverfahren mehr tempo
ermöglicht wir brauchen eine koalition
die für weltoffenheit steht und für
marktwirtschaftliche lösungen eine
koalition die europa stärkt und die
gemeinsam mit den gleichgesinnten
demokratien in der welt die
herausforderungen der zukunft
gestaltet eine koalition die einen
beitrag leistet für eine bessere welt
dafür werde ich
dafür
dafür werde ich ab jetzt arbeiten jaja
haben wir ein wahlverlierer gehört
verlierer ist er hat auf jeden fall
stimmen verloren ob bei der wahl
verlierer ist wissen wir bei arminia
steht noch nicht aber es waren spannende
sätze dabei und zwar kurz
zusammengefasst angela merkel ist schuld
und ich bin der richtige mann der stunde
worin hatte wie hat armin laschet das
ausgedrückt er sagt natürlich keiner so
offen ohne amtsbonus wird das ein enger
wahlkampf haben wir immer gewusst dass
war die versteckte kritik an angela
merkel das kanzleramt nicht vorher
übergeben zu haben und damit die macht
für die union zu sichern ganz klare
kritik an angela merkel womit armin
laschet versucht schuld für dieses
katastrophen ergebnis von sich
wegzuschieben der zweite interessante
satz ja wir müssen die weichen stellen
für die 20er jahre wir erinnern uns alle
die 20er jahre sind als chaos jahre im
historischen gedächtnis als weg quasi in
den zweiten weltkrieg 20er jahre muss
man also stabil hat wir müssen
gegensätze überwinden was sagt man
überall armin laschet der mann der immer
gegensatz zu überwinden kann diese rede
man hat sind die betretenen gesichter
der cdu geguckt war das beste was er
noch für sich herausholen konnte mit den
zwei zentralen botschaften ich bin nicht
schuld aber ich bin der richtige mann
für diese komplizierte situation
[Musik]